comment peut-on maintenir un projet de
réforme
lorsque le conseil d'état déplore des
projections financières lacunaire
précisant même que certaines
dispositions sont contraires à la
constitution
le coût de votre entêtement dépasse déjà
les économies que vous souhaitez
réaliser à travers ce projet procédure
accélérée commission spéciale ordonnance
uniquement pour faire adopter par le
parlement un projet de loi non financées
et qui pourrait être revu et corrigé par
la conférence de financement dans deux
mois un scandale démocratique pour
imposer une réforme injuste
aujourd'hui tout est mis en oeuvre pour
priver le parlement et donc les français
d'un vrai débat sur la réforme des
retraites qui est un sujet profondément
humain une affaire de vie une question
sociale majeure comment pouvez-vous
demander à l'assemblée nationale de
voter votre réforme qui va déterminer la
vie de millions de français
je rappelle ses 320 milliards d'euros
par an 14 % de la richesse nationale
sans qu'elles ne soient financés et vous
savez très bien qu'il ne peut y avoir de
justice sociale social sans équilibre
financier
le conseil d'état ne garantit même pas
la sécurité juridique de votre texte une
adolescente de 16 ans fait face
quasiment seul à une vague de haine et
de violence sans précédent et n'est plus
scolarisé en effet pour le seul crime
d'avoir critiqué une religion l'islam
il n'y a pas de racisme dans le fait de
critiquer une religion quelle qu'elle
soit l'islam comme toutes les autres
religions doit se soumettre à la
critique à l'humour et aux lois de la
république
la france s'est fracturé les français
sont divisés
et pendant ce temps en même temps un
grand nombre de ministres s'engagent
dans les élections municipales
soit en étant candidat soit en déployant
leurs énergies pour faire campagne
soutenir des candidats
certes la tâche de maire et d'adjoints
est extrêmement noble et j'ai un très
grand respect
j'ai un respect infini pour les maires
de france mais pour autant est il
possible à un ministre de se détourner
de sa mission en s'engageant dans les
élections locales le poste de ministre
n'est t'il pas un poste à temps plein le
bilan de la délinquance en 2019 et move
tous les indicateurs publiés
discrètement par le ministre d'intérieur
sont au rouge
il est loin le temps où le ministre
l'intérieur présenté les résultats de
son action devant la presse à la lecture
des chiffres on comprend cette humilité
nouvelle notre assemblée a introduit la
possibilité pour les maires et les
présidents de départements de déroger à
la règle des 80 km heure sur le réseau
secondaire
or vous venait d'adresser monsieur le
ministre aux préfets une circulaire dont
le contenu traduit manifestement une
volonté de faire obstacle à usage de
cette dérogation
les tronçons dont la vitesse pourrait
être levé à 90 km/heure devrait faire au
moins 10 km sans aucune intersection ni
riverains des tronçons de surcroît
interdit aux engins agricoles et sur
lesquelles il serait désormais
impossible d'effectuer des dépassements
les termes de cette circulaire traduit
une profonde méconnaissance de notre
réseau secondaire et des difficultés que
nous rencontrons pour nous déplacer
[Musique]